freddy krueger jason and mike myers have
invaded boulder city
they have all they're all a part of tom
devlin's monster museum making it the
perfect place to visit this halloween
season
and jc is live with more details jc are
you okay
are you okay i'm rocking my nerves
already my hands are already shaking my
nerves are kicking in right here
i'm here with tom devlin it's his
monster museum tom why open a monster
museum
we're here to preserve the art and
history of practical effects when it
comes to special makeup effects and
practical creatures
outside the digital world we want to
show the history so we start with the
silent films and work our way all the
way up to modern day who is this guy
we're looking at right here nosferatu
graf warlock himself maxwell shrek
and this is everything within the museum
i've custom sculpted it's all
one-of-a-kind works of art you won't
find it anywhere else let's walk through
it because
you have added so i've been here two
years ago you added so much more so much
is new who is this guy we're looking at
right now it's lon chaney senior as the
phantom of the opera one of his
most uh classic known roles he was the
world's first
makeup artist when it comes to american
film okay also quasimodo from the uh
quasimodo is right here okay we like
quasimodo
we go walking through you got a coffin
or some other stuff oh there's something
this
oh it's alive so
in the months of october some some of
our monsters do come to life
yeah like uh it's a lot is it sorry it
is alive it's
really cute all right let's go down here
about 25 seconds as we go uh
through october frankenstein in the
evenings we have a
nightmare at the monster museum all
right uh we got wolfman over here
yeah wolf man you're proud some movies
too like this one here this is is that
carrie from
no this is the exercise exercise girl
sure it's very nice very scary to
actually see this girl
so oh and you're
actually having actually this girl uh
crawling out from underneath the
exorcist girl as
as well all right uh we gotta ready to
wrap it up here tom hi nice to meet you
down there
my heart's pounding here oh last one
behind you what do we got here
one of the most classic uh rubber
monsters ever planet of the apes planet
of the age
the guy from this the guy from alien
right yeah that's our uh
geiger and she's still down here scaring
me you guys all right i gotta wrap it up
by sending you guys back in to see you i
actually i blacked out after that you
guys scared me
coming up on the floor back to you guys
i'm impressed j.c i would have
i wouldn't have made it i wouldn't have
made it when i saw her pop out of the
bed
that one would have freaked me out all
right jc